police in portland oregon are bracing
for protests to escalate today and
tonight with demonstrators and counter
demonstrators expected to be out in
force
saturday marked the city's 100th
consecutive night of protests demanding
racial justice
nearly 60 people were arrested lilia
luciano in portland shows us why the
situation remains so volatile
protesters supporting the black lives
matter movement took to the streets for
the
and first night in a rose sunday this is
pretty much how things always start
it's always like a peaceful gathering
demonstration started peacefully
saturday but it escalated when police
tried to turn back the crowd from
marching toward their east precinct
police used tear gas to clear the
streets
at one point engulfing our crew which
got run over as police attempted to push
back protesters
the cops are right here they're rushing
us
a man was set on fire as protesters
threw fire bombs
he was taken to a hospital according to
police who arrested 59
people saturday night into sunday
morning reportedly the highest number
since protests began
in may
protest organizers have been calling for
substantial cuts to the portland police
budget
this is all stuff that they actually
shot me braxton has been protesting for
months
he showed us a box filled with tear gas
canisters and other munitions
he says law enforcement has used against
him we have a constitutional right to be
able to assemble peacefully on public
property and as long as that rights in
fringe will keep showing up
last night even without declaring a riot
police detained several protesters
telling some
to go home or go to jail today there's
going to be a big pro-trump rally
rolling through town in cars last time a
day started like that
it ended deadly tony we hope it stays
peaceful lilia thank you very much